pero no me dió france24 conmigo en el
estudio daniel hablando onda ni de la
buena noche bienvenida comenzamos
hablando de las medidas de joe vayan
contra el cambio climático que tocaran
directamente al sector petrolero
raúl buenas noches una de ellas tiene
que ver con los subsidios a los
combustibles fósiles que el mandatario
calcula en 40.000 millones de dólares y
que pedirá al congreso su eliminación y
otra que amenaza con ser muy polémica es
la suspensión en la medida de lo posible
de las nuevas concesiones de petróleo y
gas natural en áreas federales y en
aguas territoriales
permítanme ser claro sé que es una duda
que siempre surge no vamos a prohibir el
fracking protegeremos los trabajos y los
haremos crecer incluso mediante
estándares más estrictos como controles
de fugas de metano y trabajadores
sindicalizados dispuestos a implementar
los cambios y como respuesta algunos
directivos de petroleras ya criticaron
la decisión y dicen que afectará miles
de empleos en las zonas que dependen
exclusivamente de esta actividad
daniela y se llevó a cabo
la jornada virtual del foro económico
mundial en davos y con un hito por
primera vez después de 12 años de
ausencia el presidente ruso vladimir
putin participó en el foro y pidió
reducir las tensiones sociales e
internacionales provocadas por la
pandemia
otro tema que movió la agenda fue el de
la descarbonización de la economía
global de aquí a 2030 este miércoles fue
lanzada justamente una iniciativa
llamada misión posible de lo que trata
es que en 10 años se elimine el carbón
como combustible en algunas de las
industrias más contaminantes por ejemplo
raúl la aviación los productos químicos
el acero el aluminio o los camiones lo
difícil será llegar a este punto
blackrock que es el fondo de inversión
más grande del mundo calcula que se
necesitan entre 3 y 6 billones de euros
para lograrlo y la reserva federal de
eeuu se reunió por primera vez con joe
biden como presidente sí señor después
de su reunión de dos días decidió
mantener intactas las tasas de interés
pues esto servirá para alentar el
consumo de las personas de paso aviso
que la recuperación económica se está
desacelerando por el resurgimiento del
virus estamos muy lejos de una
recuperación total algo así como 9
millones de personas permanecen
desempleadas como consecuencia de la
pandemia es la misma cantidad de
personas que perdieron sus trabajos en
lo más grave de la crisis financiera
mundial muchas pequeñas empresas están
bajo presión y hay otras necesidades que
deben abordarse en el camino a seguir
que es bastante incierto
daniela en perú el gobierno señores
impuestos al cigarrillo y alcohol si
mire el ministerio de economía y
finanzas explicó que este impuesto tiene
una actualización periódica y que busca
desincentivar el consumo de productos
que primero dañan el medio ambiente y
segundo
la salud de las personas este año subirá
para la cerveza el cigarrillo el tabaco
las bebidas alcohólicas de más de 20
grados y el tradicional pisco peruano
pero el gobierno cree que no habrá
mayores fluctuaciones en el precio final
al consumidor por ejemplo una cajetilla
cigarrillo dependiendo de si es de 10 o
de 15 unidades no subiría más del 53 por
ciento y los precios del pisco de las
cervezas subirían menos del 1 por ciento
hay otras bebidas que seguirán con los
mismos impuestos que traían en 2020 como
por ejemplo el vino o aquellas que
tienen menos de 20 grados de alcohol
entre menos emborraché pues menos
impuestos pero el pisco igual se le
puede llevar a sufrir entonces porque no
va a estar tan caro danielle indicadores
mire hubo día de caídas pronunciadas en
la bolsa de nueva york- su principal
índice el dow jones tuvo su mayor
descenso desde octubre las bolsas
europeas también experimentaron
descensos debido al retraso en la
entrega de vacunas y en américa latina'
sexta caída consecutiva para la bolsa de
sao paulo para finalizar que nos trae
como cifra el día esta semana de
resultados empresariales- raúl vemos
quienes han ganado y quienes han perdido
entre los ganadores el grupo de
telecomunicaciones everis son facebook y
tesla como cosas ganancias y entre
quienes perdieron extra otro grupo de
telecomunicaciones haití en ti también
las aerolíneas boing y delta con más de
10 mil millones de dólares
negativa como observamos así es daniela
como siempre muchísimas gracias por toda
la información económica a ustedes
también gracias continué con nosotros
acá en france 24 porque hay mucho más
por haber aquí en nuestro canal
[Música]